oui on va proposer de faire masse que
singer et là j'ai carrément envoyé chier
le producteur don qui me présente
matzinger j'ai dit mais tu crois que tf1
vouloir que j'anime ça il y avait non
méthaniques passé combal qui va animer
un bon mais je vais faire le jury avec
qui a non mais tu fais pas le jury toi
toi tu vas chanter déguisant courgettes
donc je dis donc en gros je t'ai ouvrir
mais en avait jeté ouvert la porte de la
télé on a fait vingt ans que tu écris tu
as fait ta fortune grâce à ce que j'ai
fait à la télé et là en tant qu ancien
producteur de vincent lagaf le seul
souvenir que tu es pour moi c'est de me
faire chanter déguisant qu'on jette va
bien de faire [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que voir s est dark a été
derrière benzema parler de
reconnaissance non maintenant c'est
incroyable cette rigolade et c'est vrai
que tout le monde en a parlé aujourd'hui
est ce que vous trouvez que les stars
dont un ego surdimensionné ce que vous
comprenez la guerre vous avez oui mais
non c'est vrai que valérie benaïm tu
comprends toi là oui mais je comprend
effectivement parce que dans dans le
passif entre hervé hubert et vincent
lagaf ils ont avancé ensemble il a le
sentiment que ils se sont ils ont grandi
ensemble ils ont gagné beaucoup d'argent
ensemble ils ont vécu une histoire un
succès une vraie success story 1 parce
que hervé hubert et vincent lagaf
c'était des méga stars et c'était un
méga producteurs grâce à vincent et donc
le fait que tout d'un coup quand vincent
n'est plus dans la lumière qu hervé
hubert et le rappelle alors je sais pas
dans quel terme je sais pas comment est
ce qu il a été maladroit ou s'il a
vraiment dit comme ça on va me l'a dit
comme ça c'est vrai que c'est on va
montrer tout ce qu'ils ont fait ensemble
c'est incroyable regardez vous a fait
une petite cour d'appel
[Applaudissements]
y
[Musique]
at il quelqu'un de république qui a
envie de gagner du pognon
[Applaudissements]
de passer son
bac a pris bien là je
vois si la dent
on
[Musique]
devant le
juge je te prie et merci à la vie de
barbie un telle épreuve les lignes ter
bus oui attraperait je ne n'étais pas
dans la conversation et peut-être que ça
partait d'un bon sentiment de la part
le fait que justement il s'est dit j'ai
envie de remettre vincent / sur tf1
chaque commentaire
que je peux faire je fais pas tf1 bleus
de peut-être pas en animateurs ne peut
être pas dans le jury je lui fais une
propre alors
pour ouvrir un peu vous est ce qu'ils
les animateurs qui avait le plus gros
ego qui vous avez travaillé dit la
vérité l'animateur christophe dechavanne
ah ouais ouais j'ai travaillé christophe
et c'est vrai que l'état n'avait qu'un
an mais c'est normal on tombait même que
sa fille il a révolutionné la télé way
avant avant lui il y avait un genre de
télé un peu corsetée quand il est arrivé
il a cassé les codes donc c'est normal
qu'à un moment tu te dit heureux sur le
champ ivory
williams et un égo énorme affaire même
comme ça que c'est qui pour vous c'est
vous non je t'ai bingé pas d'égouts mois
ah ouais vous n'aviez pas d'ego tu as
une mauvaise réputation dans le passé
mais rien
n'était joué moi je vous dit tout on a
tous à un égo un géant douce avec vous
mais moi notamment quand si vous ne m'a
appelé pour vous remplacer dans la
nouvelle star c'était encore à la
question à l'époque m'a proposé de venir
faire des pmp et c'est vrai que je vis à
l'époque du coup de pigeons petit je
suis pas chroniqueur je suis animateur
marc la saison donc le jeu babe alors me
demandez moi noir le devenir nasa
c'est vrai que
c'était d'avoir une connerie parce
qu'effectivement je n'ai pas mesuré je
dois reconnaître l'ampleur du phénomène
très très honnêtement et puis c'est vrai
que chroniqueur je vous dis franchement
je me sens plus je comprends je me sens
plus animateur chroniqueur même si
maintenant j'ai trouvé une place voilà
et un rôle dans l'émission mais j'avais
pas envie de faire chroniqueurs donc
j'ai refusé et mais l'ego d'un animateur
évidemment qui en a mais dans le cas de
vincent lagaf pour le coup le producteur
quand il dit qu'il a rendus riches
s'essayeront pas vraiment de très riche
passé n'ont pas de dizaines de millions
d'euros bien sûr débris même présenté
alors à chanel des vols de la boîte du
derby ibère et de vincent lagaf on parle
de plus de 100 millions d'euros 100
millions et ben oui oui mais attendez on
part on parle de près effectivement moi
je sais que quand tf1 ça allait moins
bien avec eux qui m'ont appelé pour
faire plongeurs dans splash c'est
dégueulasse vécu la
rigueur parce qu'ils m'ont appelée buy
newey alors est ce que tu veux faire ce
plh du coach pour l'animer non non c'est
pour le connais mais non non parce que
c'était l'époque et ses traits pour que
tu te fais tu en veux tu en voilà pour
faire des plongeons jedessine blague
j'ai effectivement envoyé chez
prodigieuse jour là la personne du
défunt qui d'après certains beaucoup
d'élèves ont
fait toute ma gueule quoi vous allez
vous avez non mais vous avez franchement
faire saadé alors je me sens pas énorme
mais demander avec la raison au désarroi
des tas de choses des grands prime time
tu peux pas faire le plongeur dans
splash ou la courgette dans ma figure
c'est se [ __ ] de la gueule du monde
doit jouer on a vraiment sauvé s'est pas
associée hâtif en plus quand je vois la
base c'est cela et franchement je me
demande même si pas limite fait exprès
pour mettre un petit coup de vieux
succès c'est qu'il l'animateur qui a le
plus d'ego à aller plus loin je pense
que christophe on avait beaucoup mais
c'est vrai que moi car il est
proportionnel avec son talent avec moi
christophe des j'ai une relation très
très sympa et moi j'étais fan de
dechavanne quand il était un peu un peu
d'un creux de la vague on se voyait
beaucoup c'est vrai que quand il est
revenu avec avec la roue de la fortune a
pressé il est redevenu question déjà
donc les témoins d'accessible mais ça
c'est normal mais si on avait tous fait
le quart ne soit carrière qu'en ce
moment pas maman pour avoir une tête
comme ça avant guillaume - non pour
rebondir sur la ferme ajoute que tf1 ils
ont aucun tact et aucun respect aux
amateurs il vire des mecs qui ont animé
des émissions à succès pendant des
années ils reviennent avec un grand
sourire comme si c'était une opportunité
de ouf d'être candidat dans leurs
rythmes house you do you fait
ça ils ont fait ça avec vincent cerutti
dans sa propre édition ils ont viré
d'audace ils l'ont repris en candidat
mais c'est honteux mais quand on a été
une star du paf comme ça et comme malgré
tout la gaffe a disparu aujourd'hui
dernier ces gens là non mais il faut les
soigner mais sauf que l'on fait c'est
comme l'a dit benjamin hier et valérie
l'a rappelé c'est à la fois
l'ingratitude est à la fois l'amnésie
c'est à dire que si on doit mettre en
courgettes et si on doit surfer sur sa
notoriété massa va bénéficier aux
programmes et moi je voulais savoir en
fait je pense que le nerf de la guerre
c'est l'argent
la gaffe ciment pas d'argent il accepte
pas cependant rihanna n'ont accepté mais
voilà mais je pense qu'elle agrafe
d'ailleurs pas besoin besoins des
formules moins d'argent et c'est une
question de vie ou de mort est donc en
fait je pense que le nerf de la guerre
c'est l'argent dans ces cas là on est un
exutoire en fait
surveillants pas moi en tout cas non
franchement et je comprends qu'ils
étaient vexés d'être mais non il ya même
des artistes franchement qui n'ont pas
beaucoup de l'oseille vous n'étions pas
envie de faire des choses là sur arte et
on leur donnait eu d'argent il m'est
donné c'est pas près de deux ans après
moi j'ai pas envie de dire ça y est
c'est une vie après il n'y a aucune
honte quand on est dans la merde je vous
le dis ça je vais pas que c'était faux
procès quand on a plus de boulot qu'on a
moins de 2 millions on vous propose de
la danse avec les stars ont fait pas
cent mille euros c'est beaucoup d'argent
il faut accepter silva de honte à le
faire bernard montiel vous voyez c'est
drôle parce qu'il m'est arrivé un truc
un peu comme ça je suis viré je rappelle
en mars 2003 viré de tf1 avec raison
hockey et en juin il ya un nice people
qui était lancé présenté par dechavanne
et non dur et
me demande ma demande on aimerait bien
que tu reviennes je dis ah bon mais où
ma vie virer ya deux mois non on est
revenus reviennent et moi pareil jeudi
mme pour l'animer sans doute non non non
pour que tu rentres tandis dans le truck
fonction
quand de chavannes accepte c'était une
condition d'euros pour
moi je dis si tu veux revient à tf1 tu
va d'abord faire en effet nice people ça
fonctionne très très bien les gens l'ont
adoré parce que la rti rebondir et on
fait juste derrière l'année d'après
enfin dans l'est dans la foulée lui est
moins présente les 100 plus grands
exactement agrément après les avoir
battus mais vraiment toi quand un mec
ita ita comédie benjamin 100 millions il
a vendu des bois grâce à vincent lagaf
moi j'aurais bien aimé en loyauté qui
lui plaît ya mis tout leur pose pas et
si tf1 lui proposa ton pote lagaffe
j'aurais aimé qu'ils commun dit valérie
c'est maladroit envoie quelqu'un d'autre
demandez moi j'aurais dit on allait lui
demander moi j'y vais pas aller je peux
pas me permettre de lui demander ça je
peux pas lui dire un mec qui a fait ma
fortune j'ai ma maison j'ai tout tout ce
que j'ai autour de moi c'est en partie
grâce à la gaffe tu peux pas lui dire
tient demain tu fais l'aubergine faire
passer pour un con devant tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
isabelle
j'étais en train de réfléchir à ce que
disait raymond ça m'arrive et mais je
suis assez d'accord ils voient les
riches je pense que c'est une immense
maladresse de la passe d'un d'hervé
guibert qui s'est peut-être dit emballé
on peut le faire orange s'attaque heure
d'hiver et qui dit ça va permettre de
rebondir et peut-être la refermer
derrière orange est et c'est vrai que
dans ma singer sera la
compagnie passé vous essayer d'être
gentil mais la gaffe louette a raison de
se mettre en couple rebondir il est venu
à ses 8 il a fait du bowling il est
parti après à 2 sur tf1 est repartie
elle sur son voyage il avait besoin de
visibilité en cours j'ai tu me diras mec
qu'on n'a pas vue depuis sans fin si
vite et reviens julien lepers il revient
aux courgettes il faut leur dire mais là
cela s'entend on n'a pas besoin d'eux
mais voilà il au mexique dont il y en a
ils ont pas besoin et je vais la chanson
alors oui non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
des modes à lattes et parle de chavannes
il est plus à la mode ça va être
compliqué de revenir mais on peut
respecter et il a fait la fenêtre en
bois on veut respecter ce qu'il a été ne
pas lui proposer d'être encore jette
dans une émission à dechavanne ou pareil
pour la gaffe même si c'est plus
compliqué aujourd'hui après ça va quand
on est tous des ego et parfois ridicule
parce que franchement là j'avais de gros
test dans ce que je vais dire mais moi
il ya quatre ans quand il m'a appelé
pour danse avec les stars mais que
j'étais un rendez vous avec fat pedrazza
à tf1 le producteur du producteur pardon
mais j'étais persuadé que je déploie des
climats
et je me suis dit bon ben voila merci
route il commence à cartonner chez vous
moi ça fait 15 ans que je rêvais tf1 je
vois la sirène a mis le pied à l'étrier
j envoie un cyril
trétout changer ses adorables gym
ailleurs à votre aise 14 prime
dida et c'est vrai que j'ai été hyper
mixée alors qu'en fait comme lui dit
quand on lui a dit que c'est aux
candidats à gauche il m'a dit quoi si
vous à 17 ans candidat vous avez dit
bête et 18,6 belle non mais je suis pas
non plus un repreneur parce que je me
dis qu'est ce qui m'attire et bernard ce
qui m'a vexé et franchement j'adore
pedraza grands producteurs ce qui m'a
vexé c'est que il est un petit peu
laissé entendre après le côté comme ils
font souvent le court ces écoutes tu
viens tu es candidat et si t'es pas
virer sur les premiers prix mais quel
est mon vote et qu'on voit que ça prend
un peu ta tête derrière tu m'a intéressé
la chaîne mais il manque ce petit côté
c'est horrible du parent sondage pour
savoir affiché normalement
sauf que c'est vrai il n'a pas menti sur
ce qu effectivement on fait revenir des
visages pour les familiariser pour que
l'été spectateurs s'habituer à eux et
petit à petit on les fait monter
non mais
j'ai l'impression qu'à chaque fois
qu'ils ont et vous ont appelé ils vous
ont fait descendre en fait je suis monté
c'est vrai qu'il ya un gros ego de la
télé ou pas pour les téléspectateurs il
ya vraiment des animateurs qui sont qui
a même eu une balle de franchement le
plus gros mois chez lui c'est de
chavannes je reconnais pas vraiment
vraiment vraiment je vois là après
freezer s'inclinant excuses a pas que
des maths en fait balancer ce que
j'appelle des lits matters et quand ils
sont très haut ils sont souvent aux yeux
quand ils descendent ils sont adorables
et tu te dis comme ça va remonter vont
être adorable et redevienne odieux bon
moi j'ai eu une mauvaise port sec nagui
par exemple boire un thé ni matters mais
quand il avait plus rien du tout
abandonnée l'été juste producteurs il
est plus que l ombre et lumière il n'y
avait plus rien et présenter cette
émission à 23 heures il n'avait plus
rien à la boîte de prod ils viendraient
sa voiture à côté de la mienne à thann
saint denis il avait rien à [ __ ] de
ces journées il est à doha match
possible morandini sayah foucault et on
se pare elle est adorable et que ça
commence à repartir pour lui et l'a
terminé plus de réponses au téléphone
plus rien plus rien plus rien voilà
c'est une réponse à vous oui moi je
crois comprendre
moi je peux alors que quand j'étais bas
c'était joris et moroni deçà et qu'il
avait un peu besoin de lumière bas il
répondait donc voilà ça moi je pense le
contraire je pense que ce qu'on était
très haut qui auront connu tout en bas
et quand ils remontent après ça va mieux
on regarde valérie n'a jamais et sont
bien maintenant mais sans mandat et moi
je vais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les plombages même qu'il connaissait
personnellement j'aime chez
vip ensemble franchement toutes les
émissions à doha alors j'ai partagé les
âges et les bagnoles 100 célébrités
pavage
avec lui franchement vous n'avez pas il
était fou ça c'est sûr et il était fou
les gens avaient un peu la trouille de
lui parce qu'ils se disaient il peut
partir en sucette oui voilà mais en
revanche il était très bon camarade et
très partageur très très sympathique et
sanguins sanguin twilight dont
gtb comme ça mais j'ai toujours pensé
que des salles n'étaient pas des stars
dont j'avais beaucoup d'unités par
rapport à ma notoriété
bah oui oui bien dans mon district faut
pas oublier quand même ce que même en un
métier privilégié magnifique on est
heureux de faire mais on est souvent
traité comme de la merde ah oui très
souvent on et vous plus rien postaux les
bonnes questions
vous avez traité comme de la merde
évidemment tu leur dis que vous
commencez à tomber au traité comme de la
merde vous n'existez vraiment plu à
savait vraiment
ce que vivent peut-être la plupart des
français on décompte tombe de piédestal
on est de la merde n'existe plus on vaut
rien et c'est pour ça que quand on
remonte ça oui bah oui quoi c'est
valérie ça vous et non mais il faut se
demander ce qu'il faut et ce qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est qu'on fait un métier
dans la lumière qui est absolument
formidable mais qu on ait une sorte de
produit on est notre propre produit
notre nous confronte fait du marketing
sur nous mêmes pour pour être que les
gens nous aiment et c est il que les
gens nous aiment ou pas on a beau
travailler super bien et c'est parfois
ça prend ça prend pas et on ne sait pas
pourquoi c'est comme un comédien il
imprime une imprime pas et aussi faut
savoir que la télévision c'est pas comme
le cinéma les gens aussi peuvent vous
oublie assez vif quand même donc il faut
il faut c'est ce que j'ai produit une
table avec moi pas s'arrêter interne on
m'a parfois je vous plains
les gens sont persuadés que conduit fait
la télévision bas tous les soirs au
resto du tapis rouge t'as machin tu as
tout mais en vrai c'était un
salary quoi qu'est ce que tu vas au
resto et en plus tu payes pas toi non
avec des séries comme dans n'importe
quelle s est tu peux te faire moi j'y
joue j'ai été viré le mais le matin le
major je n'en savais pas le matin pour
le soir j'étais viré après dix ans comme
un mec chez renault chez france télécom
du thé salariés tu t'es juste la tam
était dans la logique du coin ils vous
ont dit que la balle était à l'époque
c'était l'instant brossard le patron et
bien ils m'ont dit quoi franchement le
matin il me dit est ce que tu veux venir
dans le bureau mais dont j'étais
persuadé que c'était pour renouveler le
contrat est pour eux
est en fait puisqu'on va se passer
j'arrive dans le bureau et puis le débat
attend un petit peu avant qu'on se parle
dollar entraîne juge attend un petit peu
et puis j'ai pour projet il fait tenir
s'il te plaît et l'art est une personne
la drh et du juridique chez ses parents
et puis en fait ils étaient trois et
puis ils m'ont dit voilà on va arrêter
mais je faisais arrêter quoi et des
trottoirs
non m'arrête oui
oui c'est à dire on arrête toi voilà et
donc léger bras pourquoi ben alors en
fait ce qui m'avait dit c'est qu'à
l'époque qui voulait il voulait changer
l'image de la chaîne et c'est ce qui m'a
dit clairement et que j'étais l'étendard
de quelque chose qu'il est nous les plus
représentés hélas tu as dit peut-être
pris un coup sur la tête bah oui je sors
du bureau tu dois être au bout de table
à base de la vérité alors je sors du
bureau je j'appelle mon meilleur ami
qu'était fogiel et je lui dis je suis
viré et voilà c'est pas salé des
salariés dont j'ai pu rien et je me suis
dit qu'est ce que je vais faire et comme
j'ai pas dit si tu avais pas
propriétaire ni rien je me suis dit là
il m'a dit premier truc que tu fais
vente à bagnols tu vas vivre quelques
mois avec et je vous jure que c'est vrai
une semaine après j'étais à boulogne le
téléphone sonne numéro inconnu je
réponds j'entends bébé
qui est décédé c'était vous qui
m'appelait dans la rue et qui me dit est
ce que tu veux venir faire des
chroniques et des machins exactement à
une semaine près comme comme ça que ça
s'est passé j'ai suivi un petit peu
l'accusé vous étiez
genre calme et ça s'est passé voilà une
semaine comme ça ouais ouais c'est vous
et vous comment il faut le garder en
tête ça donne quand on fait partie de
france télé aussi cette verdure non mais
enfin c'était c'était particulier parce
que moi je suis c'est moi qui suis
partie je partis de tf1 et je suis parti
de france télévision parce que moi j'ai
besoin d'être désiré c'est à dire j'ai
besoin que ça marche dans les deux sens
qu'on me dise on a envie de toi on a
besoin de toi etc et quand on sent que
ça ça fonctionne pas de toute façon on
va délivrer quelque chose qui va pas
être bien l'été sécateur vont le sentir
mais effectivement il ya une vie à une
sorte de petite mort c'est à dire qu'à
un moment le téléphone sonne plus
vraiment alors on veut c'est là où on
voit la garde rapprochée bien mais c'est
là où moi je dis tout le temps il faut
penser que la télé c'est un métier mais
il faut avoir pleins d'autres métiers
annexes faire de la radio écrire des
livres etc pour pas tout d'un coup se
retrouvèrent dans sa longue et jamais
pour ce jeu pour qu' il n'est pas ce
truc d'abyssales de thomas berger le
vide j'ai plus rien bien sûr il donc
voilà il ya des demandeurs sont souvent
animateurs producteurs parce que sinon
ben ça peut directeur des programmes
kemp nagl et ben t'es tu perds ta put
rien on est des chiens dangereux
que génération
non mais moi je peux me faire virer du
jour au lendemain et si oui les mains et
enfin pour les goûts maintenant on est
tranquille
[Applaudissements]
trigaux il a changé en 11 ans tpm p pas
du tout non non vraiment je n'ai pas
changé
alors moi qui vous connaît depuis
longtemps mais se trouve alors vous avez
des plus beaux costumes et des plus
belles marques mais vous n'avez pas
changé sur le comportement des journées
de bagnols toujours les finger et de
javel travail routier développé du coup
à pour changer la donne est ce que c'est
possible d'avoir des cdi
mais
ce métier il est basé sur l'air du temps
donc tu voyais pas avoir assez des
foyers s'équipent en adéquation avec la
der à
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
un truc très simple il faut en avoir
conscience c'est à dire que on fait ce
métier aussi pour ça aussi mais aussi
parce que c'est justement ça m'était sur
le fil parce que tous les matins
justement je ne sais pas ce qui va se
passer c'est aussi ça qui nous fait
tenir c'est l'adrénaline et c'est donc
il ya le revers de la médaille il faut
que je suis fou il ya bien un truc très
important kelly à huy elle a dit un truc
le le cdi parce que autrefois les gens
ils voulaient pas exaucés billets parce
que gagner beaucoup plus à la piste est
maintenant signe des temps un cdi ou
est-ce que ça rassure et ça c'est
quelque chose de sûre non c'est très
embarrassant donc faire un emprunt comme
des ombres à la journée
badge c'est pareil partout le basque est
désactivé un nouveau mx ou au tout la
balade sur le plateau qui a le plus gros
ego
mathieu a le vent en poupe à moisdon
avec moi d'un mois abandonnée pardon oui
mais non mais non enfin
melon vous plaisantez
vous avez une tête
je prends pas
[Applaudissements]
parti comme ça pourquoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas d'accord
mais la ville vous osez dire ça j'ai
débuté ma petite chemise comme ça il
vous fait comme ça dans la rue vous
dans la cage on dit bonjour on nous
regarde regardez dans le miroir votre
reflet vous je suis bon aujourd'hui
mais toi oui oui ça va ça ça vous plaît
ça va ça va tuer m tu vois c'est vrai ce
qu'il dit bah on a le même défaut chez
eux comme vous c'est vrai ah oui c'est
vrai qu'on sent guère plus doux que les
autres non c'est parce
qu'israël fait j'aime beaucoup cette
personne il parle de nuit ont quand même
baissé
et libé novelli a annoncé qu'elle me
souviens assez calmes et ça
c'est pas vrai kelly plein non là moi
moi ce que je peux dire que j'ai là j'ai
encore beaucoup de pression
lâchez vous
alors je confirme ce que dit mathieu je
confirme ce que dit benjamin feilles à
un moment donné où il va falloir un peu
redescendre sur terre
on est jeune tourné vers mes deux amis
allez raymond idiot oui c'est
l'incarnation de la modestie merci
mais attention à votre physique à vos
vêtements cyril et animateur producteur
mais aussi mannequin
merci merci gravure et mon temps pour
aller plus loin je le prends comme un
entraîneur de foot vous êtes là vous
coacher les gens vous êtes obligé de
dégager ça il est obligé de regarder on
vient voir de faire le gorille comme
c'est
vrai c'est l'entraîneur moi l'horizon
régula bien
[Applaudissements]